[Music]
you always stay in fantastic shape you
are lean me shrim secretly I make a work
out by herself for a long time then the
man taste my wife sometimes now you
gotta you gotta balance marriage and
your health you have to find a balance
and Plus ladies need a whole lot of
attention mm-hmm you gotta find a way to
merge that attention you're gonna give
your lady with working out where's
Bennett aha we're questioning how
feelings it has to feel you want to be
able to connect with your lady so you
work out really with your lady yeah
together and and that works for you that
works perfect hello want me to do it to
come okay
all right what do i what what's what's
what's what's happening here what do I
do
okay I'm me mm-hmm and you my lady
alright how's your lady okay I guess
yeah you're gonna say my friend seemed
to immediately accept that via you my
lady I'm on me I'm here you're here
you're here I only beat me cuz I'm here
daddy's not here so you got me my lady
I'll be I'm your lady okay let's do it
you understand yeah yeah okay it sounds
like real real sound campfire Lodge yeah
but this is a real coup exercise and
there's something and this these these
exercises are just as athletic and and
physical as they are erotic
okay okay so now what am I doing here
you're gonna do push-ups on my knees
while I'll do crunches you want me to do
push-ups on your knees well you do
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay now you must also remember to
communicate with your lady while you're
exercising ladies attention okay turn
around turn around turn around turn
around
Judy says now
and thank you yeah for now we're gonna
do dips you're gonna do dips oh do dips
now dip come on work it come on baby get
some day is this enough for me that's it
for you yeah okay
you gonna dip baby dip
[Applause]
Hey I'm so sorry I forgot hey you are my
wind I forgot I forgot go ahead it's
okay
all right the series premiere of the
Millers Thursdays at 8:30 on CBS
[Applause]